hello everyone neo fighting Morpheus it
really doesn't get any better than that
and such is the case in the chess world
world reigning champion in classical
time control Magnus Carlsen facing the
world reigning champion in blitz it
really doesn't get better than that
and not only that Sergey Kerrigan was
actually the Challenger for the
classical time control championship last
year so these two there whatever the
either of them does there are rivals for
life so here they face each other in the
world blitz championship and again it's
quite a game and if you've seen the
world the World Chess Championship last
year it was it was quite a match the the
match couldn't be decided in classical
time format so they had you know a
resort to other time formats and in the
end Carlson won with a brilliant Queen
sacrifice on h6 and one would think okay
you lost that game I mean you had to go
for a win in that game but probably in
every other game you will be very
careful what Carlsen does on the h6
square but this game shows that's not
really the case but you'll see what I
mean by that so let's see the game cross
in place efore with the white pieces and
we have E 5 starting off with probably
the real Lopez Knight to f3 Knight to c6
and Bishop to b5 we have the rule opus
although crosslinker can did have some
amazing games in the Italian but this
game crossing goes for the Royal opus
and we have Knight to f6 the Berlin
defense d3 Bishop to c5 Bishop captures
and D captures and c6 kurakin goes for
the alpha 0 variation of the real hope
is very interesting Knight to c3 by
Carlsen we have castles Bishop to e3 and
Bishop back to b6 Bishop to g5 it seems
like Carson lost the tempo by playing
Bishop e3 and then Bishop g5 but Cara
can also move the bishop twice so it
doesn't really matter this comes with a
very nice pin on the knight on f6 and
it's always you know
principled to get your pieces as deep in
the in the in your opponent's position
as possible
so so it's a nice move rook to e8 by
kirkin and h3 not allowing any Bishop to
g4 c5 now we have Knight to d5 kind of
threatening to capture Knight captures
on f6 maybe Bishop to h6 would be a very
unpleasant position for Kerrigan and
Bishop d7 preventing this but also
allowing Coulson to grab the bishop on
e7 and take the bishop repair away from
kurakin and that's exactly what Carson
does not capture Sonny 7 this is with
Czech Queen captures only seven and
Carlsen castles we have h6 keeping the
Bishop Bishop to e3 now again the h3
pawn comes very handy you know Knight g4
ideas are possible to harass the bishop
and Knight to d7
we have Knights to d2 by Carlson Carlson
once the push f4 as Kerrigan has so
conveniently got rid of his dark square
Bishop and Corrigan does have some
counter play here he could go for b6
maybe Bishop to be 7 next but he goes
for Knights to be 8 he wants to bring
the snipe to c6
as he does have a pawn on c5 so maybe
this night could find some nice square
on on d4 not very likely because c3 is
always possible but if crossing will
push f4 then from c6 this night maybe
could come to e5 so we have F 4 by
Carlsen he captures on f4 rook captures
on f4 and now Knight comes to c6 which
may be ideas of Knight d4 or e5 in the
future and Carson immediately jumps in
to the attack Queen to h5 and I mean why
not
b6 now we have rook a to f1 cross and
doubles up on the F file and rook to a
fate there's a lot of pressure piling up
on this f6 pawn Knight to f3 by Carlsen
across all of course since pieces are
pretty much ideally placed okay this
rook might be a bit awkward on f4 but it
doesn't really matter black doesn't have
a lot of dark square bishop and this can
always go pretty much wherever it wants
the only piece that isn't ideally placed
is than item d2 and Carlsen once the
wants to fix this so Knight to f3
Bishop to e6 by kurakin and now rope 2h
and this is what I mean hurricane pretty
much lost the World Chess Championship
last year to Carlsen by Carlsen doing
something on the h6 square and the one
would think hurricane would really you
know be careful of such things carp in
place f6 the idea was probably to
capture Bishop captures h6g captures and
after Queen captures there would be some
terrible threats of queen h7 checkmate
or queen h8 checkmate sokar can place f6
this stops this idea and the queen is
now ready to jump into the defense and
we have Queen to g6 now Carson is
definitely threatening to play Bishop
captures or ro captures whichever will
be better depending on Kerrigan's move
and Queen to f7 kirkin offers the
exchange of Queens still lying that a to
pawn although if you look at this
position all of Carson's pieces are are
really going for carotenes King the a to
pawn doesn't really seem all that
important Queen to g3 cost and of course
declines this if you control more space
don't trade pieces and here now there is
a definite threat of something capturing
the HS exponent and you should really
not allow this especially if you lost
your World Championship title by cross
I'm doing something on h6
and here h5 the Queen is protecting h5
not allowing this rook to move that's
pretty much traps rock on edge for this
this would have been okay called a
Kerrigan could have continued this game
but instead after this Queen to g3 by
Carlsen kurakin plays Knight to be for
the idea here being Knight wants to
capture on c2 threatened III so so we're
going to play basically it's it's the
move that immediately loses the game but
okay
Carson is very happy about this he plays
Bishop captures on h6
so there we have it kirkin usually you
didn't watch out for
Carlsen doing something on h6 so Bishop
captures on h6 we have Knight captures
on c2 and this is curtains idea here
cross in place on Knight to e5 the pawn
can't capture the night because you lose
the Queen obviously your capture screen
the problem with this move is the Queen
has to keep an eye on the GCL
square otherwise queen chapters on g7
will be checkmate the only square from
which the Queen can't keep an eye on g7
is actually Queen to e7 but if you play
Queen to e7 it's it's very hard very
hard for Karen to continue this then
Knight to g6 comes queen is attacked
rookies attacked this is very very
uncomfortable so after this Knight to e5
move hurricane could have gone for
something like Knight the d4 maybe I
mean it is blitz both are in time
trouble so now if you capture the Queen
night Stewie to check for cos the king
and queen this actually wins for
Kerrigan
now after King to f2 Knight captures
King captors and rook captures it's it's
a better position for black might be
even winning but I mean the ugly truth
is after night to d4 threatening this
night to be to check you can simply go
King to h1 and now there really isn't I
think you can do now the Queen would
have to move for example Queen to e7 but
now comes Knight g6 and after Queen to
d6 attacking Queen on g3 simply Bishop
to f4 and black is falling apart so
after this night - if I move Carrick and
thought ah I mean F captures on e5 he
captured night at least he will grab two
pieces for the Queen cross and played
rock captures on f7 with a rook captures
on f7 sorry Queen captures on f7 rook
captures on f7 and Queen to g6 now by
Carlsen immediately going for that
bishop on e6 making sure the Queen is on
an ideal square you have to move the
bishop somewhere Knight to d4 is
definitely an idea and it's a beautiful
square for the knight also protecting
the bishop but Cara can place the Bishop
captures on a two you know he just gave
up a queen for two pieces he thought I'm
not getting checkmated here I might as
well probably grab a pawn get some more
material advantage unfortunately this
doesn't work Bishop to g5 Carlson is now
threatening rook to h7 followed by
Bishop to f6 and there will be there
will be hell on the g7 square Kerrigan
plays rook F to f8 and probably with
ideas of Bishop coming back to f7
kicking the Queen away but Carson simply
doesn't allow this he plays
2h7 and there is nothing you can do in
this position for black you're getting
checkmate it in four moves whatever
black plays car can play rook to f7 car
across and played Bishop to f6 and in
this position world blitz reigning
champion circuit car can resigned to the
game there is really nothing you can do
the threat of course is rook captures
with check rook capture screen captures
this is checkmate and there really isn't
anything you can do here well whatever
you play really loses if you I mean it's
really hard to even make any move for
black everything loses its checkmate
into whatever black does for example
rope to d7 simply you capture a bishop
captures and it's all over I mean really
really a silly position for Kerrigan so
yeah after Bishop to f6 Sergey Cara can
resign the game and a wonderful win for
Magnus Carlsen I I do hope you enjoyed
it I mean this is there is no great
greater match up then Carlsen versus
Kerrigan in the chess world it's it's
it's like neo fighting Morpheus it's
just always amazing so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Mohamed Al Sabah and they aren't
footage for a contribution to my channel
I think a lot to really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here both of them will be from
the world blitz championship feel free
to suggest any game I can't follow all
games but I'm sure there are amazing
games played like the one on Tom quarter
both played in the last round I hope you
got a chance to check it out so make
sure you suggest an interesting game I
will check all the comments think all
for watching and I will see you soon